most people don't wake up in the morning
and ask themselves the question why do I
live in a universe of matter but they
should because if you think about it
from the point of view of fundamental
physics matter and antimatter are almost
exactly the same things for every
particle in nature there's a particle
that has equal mass and often its
opposite charge antimatter only seems
strange as I often like to say in the
sense that Belgians seem strange namely
Belgians aren't intrinsically strange
but if you go into a large auditorium as
I've often done and said how many
Belgians are there you rarely see them
antimatter seems strange because we
rarely see it why because hardly any of
it exists in the universe but if the
universe were made of antimatter it
would look exactly the same auntie
lovers could sit in auntie cars under an
anti moon and make anti love and
everything would seem exactly the same
so why do we live in a universe that has
only matter and no antimatter that's one
of the biggest mysteries in fact that's
been driving particle physics and
cosmology over the last 40 years if you
started with a sensible universe it
should I have equal amounts of matter
and antimatter how would you end up with
a universe in which for every particle
of antimatter there may be more than 10
billion particles of matter these are
questions we have ideas about how to
answer but we don't yet know exactly how
to answer and that's one of the reasons
why we're looking out in the universe to
confirm in fact the processes that might
create matter instead of antimatter and
to look for sources of antimatter in the
universe it turns out that there's there
are energetic processes involved with
black holes including the black hole at
the center of our galaxy that are
producing lots of antimatter we don't
quite understand all of those processes
some of them may be involved with exotic
stuff like dark matter some of it may be
involved with more pedestrian things
like Paul SARS and energetic magnetic
fields around stars we don't know all of
the processes and that's why we have to
keep looking and we have new tools new
windows on the universe like the Fermi
telescope which looks out in space at
high-energy gamma rays and high-energy
particles that are coming in that many
of which don't reach the earth because
of
the atmosphere or magnetic fields around
the earth each new window we have on the
universe surprises us and we may be
surprised about the sources of
antimatter are in nature and some of
those sources may help us understand
that remarkable mystery of why we live
in a universe full of matter